je le dis avec toute ma conviction
l'avortement doit rester l'exception
l'ultime recours pour des situations
sans issue mais comment le tolérer son
qu'il perd son caractère d'exception
sans que la société paraissent
l'encourager je voudrais tout d'abord
vous faire partager une conviction de
femmes
je m'excuse de le faire devant cette
assemblée presque exclusivement composée
d'hommes aucune femme ne recourt de
gaieté de coeur à l'avortement
il suffit d'écouter les femmes c'est
toujours un drame
[Applaudissements]
c'est toujours un drame
cela restera toujours un drame c'est
pourquoi si le projet qui vous est
présenté tient compte de la situation de
fait existantes
s'il admet la possibilité d'une
interruption de grossesse c'est pour la
contrôler et autant que possible en
dissuader la femme
nous pensons ainsi répondre au désir
conscient ou inconscient de toutes les
femmes qui se trouvent dans cette
situation d angoisse si bien décrite est
analysé par certaines des personnalités
de votre commission spéciale a entendu
au cours de l'automne 1973 actuellement
celles qui se trouvent dans cette
situation de détresse qui s'en préoccupe
la loi les rejette non seulement dans le
propre la honte et la solitude mais
aussi dans l'anonymat et l'angoissé
poursuite contrainte de cacher leur
étant trop souvent elle ne trouve
personne pour les écouter les éclairer
et leur apporter un appui et une
protection
parmi ceux qui combattent aujourd'hui
une éventuelle modification de la loi
répressive
combien sont ils ceux qui se sont
préoccupés d'aider ces femmes dans leur
détresse
combien sont ils ceux qui au delà de ce
qu'ils jugent comme une faute ont su
manifester aux jeunes mères célibataires
la compréhension et la plus morale dont
elle avait un si grand besoin
[Applaudissements]